بسبب ذلك الموسم الاستثنائي لنجم الصف
الاول للناشئين اشتهر في اوروبا عام 2003
تلقى عرضا من نادي الارسنال للانضمام الى
فريقه لكن رغم العرض المذهل قرر ميسي
الحفاظ على ولائه لبرشلونه كان موسم 2003
2004 اسطوريا لميسي خلال ذلك الموسم حطم
الارقام القياسيه وشارك مع خمسه فرق في
موسم واحد اذ لعب مع فريق الناشئين الثاني
والناشئين الاول وبرشلونه الثالث وبرشلونه
الثاني بسبب هذا الارتقاء السريع في
الترتيب بدا لاعبون من فريق برشلونه الاول
يميزونه خلال جلسات التدريب واصروا على
منحه فرصه في الفريق الاول
قبل وصوله حتى الى فريق برشلونه الاول كان
جميع اعضاء الفريق الاول يعرفونه في احدى
المناسبات كان كثيرون منهم في استراحه
اللاعبين الدوليين واحتاجوا الى لاعبين
للمشاركه في تدريبات الفريق الاول وكان
ميسي واحدا منهم جولي لاعب برشلونه الدولي
الفرنسي الذي شارك في جلسه التدريب يروي
قصه عن ذلك الطفل الصغير الذي كان يحطم
الجميع تماما وشعر بالغون بالاحراج امام
هذا الفتى البالغ من العمر 16 سنه في ملعب
التمرين ولم يستطع فرانك ريكارد تجاهله
وسرعان ما قال فريق برشلونه الاول انه يجب
ضم ذلك الفتى الى صفوفه
وفي تلك الفتره كان رونالدينيو نجمه
برشلونه وقد راى ميسي يتمرن واختاره ليكون
رونالدينيو التالي اي النجم المقبله
لبرشلونه وكان مصرا ان يصبح ليونيل ميسي
لاعبا في الفريق الاول للنادي مع ان ميسي
لم يلعب رسميا ضمن الفريق الاول في ذلك
الموسم فقد انهى تلك الفتره بتسجيله
اهدافا لاربعه من فرقه الخمسه بمجموع بلغ
36 هدفا في جميع المسابقات الرسميه
بالوصول الى موسم 2005
ظهر ميسي اخيرا مع فريق برشلونه الاول
للمره الاولى بنزوله الى الملعب في
الدقيقه الثانيه والثمانين في سن السابعه
عشر وثلاثه شهور اضحى ميسي اصغر لاعب يلعب
ضمن فريق برشلونه الاول فقد دخل بديلا في
مباراه ضد اسبانيول وجاء هدفه الاول بعد
ذلك مباشره فاصبح اصغر لاعب يسجل هدفا
لفريق برشلونه الاول في مواجهه نادي
الباستي في ختام ذلك الموسم والذي انتهى
عام 2005
[تصفيق]
في موسم
2006 كان ميسي لاعبا اساسيا دائما في صفوف
الفريق الاول تمت ترقيته كليا من الفريق
الثاني وراح يتمرن مع الفريق الاول بشكل
يومي خلال مبارياته القليله الاولى كان
ميسي يدهش معجبه في كلا جانبي الملعب كانت
مهاراته استعراضا يستحق المشاهده وصارت
قدراته معروفه في كل مكان يرتاده بينما
كان يافعا اخذ العالم يلاحظون وجود ميسي
ويميزه سلفا بانه احد اعظم اللاعبين في
اللعبه منذ نعومه اظافره واعتقد انه لا
يتاثر كثيرا بالجاذبيه الارضيه ويمتلك
تسارعا رهيبا وسرعه وتيره مهوله يتحرك
بانسيابيه على الارض لكنه يتمتع بقوه
بدنيه مذهله فرغم حجمه الصغير لا تتصور ان
يتمتع بتلك القوه لكنه حرفيا يركض طوال
المباريات من واحده الى اخرى دون ان يبدو
متاثرا بذلك يعاود الوقوف وتجاوز خصومه
وتبدو هزيمته مستحيله يتجاوز لاعبين اربعه
ويتجه يسره ويتجاوز لاعبا انه اصغرهم
انظروا الى ذلك لمسه مبدعه من ميسي ولديه
تلك المثابره والقوه المذهله للمواظبه على
وترته ومهارته وهي ما يميزه في تلك السن
كلاعب فريد حقا